welcome everyone to the November Meetup
thank you all for being here really
excited to have you all here thank you
thank
you so those of you who are regulars
know that the first thing I always ask
at every Meetup is anyone hiring so if
anyone's hiring now there your chance to
let everyone know so before everyone in
this room raises their hands if you are
virtual go to the NY hackr slack if you
go to Nyack r.org you'll see a hashtag
at the top you can um click on there and
find the job posting Channel if you're
posting a job
in the nyck R.S slack.com post it in the
job posting channel does anyone in
person have a job they want to hire
for no all right bad
economy okay all right so hopefully
someone virtually wants a job or is
hiring because other people do want jobs
for the people here in person the pizza
today was from Joe's Pizza so I want you
to pull out your phones is interactive
go to bit. lee/ pza Pizza pole all
lowercase and go and vote on the pizza
so bit. lee/ Pizza pole and rank the
pizza it's a fivepoint scale we've been
collecting this data since about
2011 so let us know how the pizza is and
let us know what you think people who
are at home if you're not eating piz
pizza or you are eating pizza let us
know what you're eating tell us if you
got pizza where it's from if you got
some other food let us know what it is
let us know how you're enjoying
yourselves food is a big part of this
Meetup so there's usually questions at
meetups we have in-person people and we
have virtual people so if you're in
person when it's time for questions
you'll raise your hand you'll ask a
question our speaker will repeat the
question for the audience at home now if
you're at home though and you want to
ask a question you have two choices you
could use the chat in the YouTube stream
or better you could use the monthly
Meetup chat channel on the NY hackr
slack again if you want to join that
I'll post a link in the YouTube chat but
it's Nyack r.org click the little
hashtag link and it'll take you to join
the slack and there's a channel there
called monthly Meetup chat go there to
tell me about your food go there to ask
questions and when you ask the questions
I will collate them and ask the question
of the speaker and we'll get an answer
for you all
right we want to thank NYU particularly
George for hosting us this my here's
George Ione big round of applause for
George making this
happen
they graciously hosted us I think it's
the second month in a row with more
months to come we want to uh thank them
very much for that but we now that we
have a space we need
speakers so we need a December speaker
sometimes we have this thing planned six
months in advance other times we have it
planned two weeks in advance this is one
of the two weeks months all right early
December whoever wants to give a talk
whether you're coming from the virtual
land or someone in this room I will call
on you randomly to give a talk to
everybody that happens but we need
speakers for December and January so let
me know if you want to give a talk you
can be in touch with me in person come
say hi if you're online go to jer.com
and find me find me on Meetup find me on
slack find me on LinkedIn Twitter or
anywhere find me and let me know you
want to give a talk cuz we love having
people give
talks for those of you in the room sorry
folks if you're at home we're going to
the bar afterwards whoever wants to go
to the bar you'll find us we'll lead you
there we'll probably go to arts and
crafts bar that's like the closest nice
bar around here George good all right
we'll go to arts and crafts bar after
this if you know where it is great if
you don't know where it is follow us all
right Folks at home sorry you can't join
us unless you're watching this from
somewhere nearby and you're going to
come to the bar and skip the Meetup
that's cool come on down all right so
remember everyone go to Nyack r.org to
ask your questions go there to find
previous videos and please be a
speaker other than that I think that's
all the announcements I have so everyone
please welcome first time speaker
Jason thanks Jared so yeah tonight we're
going to talk about propensity score
analysis and I'm going to try to um so
this is a very ambitious agenda we are
certainly not going to get through all
of this but um uh I'm going to try to
explain propensity score analysis with
pces which is going to install a whole
bunch of extra packages that I'm going
to use in the slide deck that aren't
actually required for the
package all right so you know propensity
scor
analysis broadly speaking is a way of
trying to estimate causality from
observational data in other words from
data that wasn't collected where you're
trying to control a treatment or control
condition um but you can observe it
later on um since the sort of initial
paper from 1983 by uh rosenbom and Ruben
you could see particularly over the last
decade or so just an increase in the
number of citations and the and the use
of propensity scores in published
literature um so some of the these are
from World of Science and Google um
analytics but what I like to you know
everybody's probably heard or heard in
their class and their stat you know
intro stats class right the randomized
control trial is the gold standard for
causality which is true but I like to
start by pointing out that the
randomized control trial is actually
already a compromise to the true causal
effect or what we call the
counterfactual um this has become a lot
easier to explain thanks to um Dr
strange and the Marvel Multiverse right
cuz really the true causal effect right
is the difference of some outcome
between the same individual presuming
everything is the same except one
condition right so here I have some
research subject in my world I do a lot
of educational research so what I want
to do is split the student into two
universes where in Universe a I give
them some condition a and universe B
they they get a different condition and
then at the same same time measure the
difference in those two things right of
course that's not possible uh Holland
called this the fundamental problem
causality right and you know the
randomized experiment really the the key
here is that there's this notion of a
strong ignorability assumption that if
you're controlling it you're flipping a
coin between who goes into the treatment
and control condition on average things
work out right so let's look at an
example so here I have some simulated
data where I've stipulated that um the
counterfactual or the difference between
the treatment control is 4.5 okay and
here I'm drawing from a distribution
with a mean 100 and a standard deviation
of 15 so to be concrete about this I'm
saying I'm going to give some
intervention that is going to increase
somebody's IQ by four and a half points
right if we want to be concrete about it
okay so these are the true
counterfactuals so each one of these is
here's a student right under the control
condition um would get this this score
and this red dot is what they would get
in the treatment condition 4.5 units
higher the spread here is just sort of
measurement noise right measurement
variability so when we do a randomized
control trial essentially we're just
observing one of those two outcomes okay
so for this student here I only see the
uh treatment condition on this student I
see the control condition etc etc right
um and if I look at this right so on the
left side if I take the average the the
blue the control conditions the average
of the red right I get this blue and red
line the difference between those is
4.5 over here I'm going to do the same
thing I'm going to take the average of
the control which is the um uh blue line
and the average of the treatments which
is the red line now note here on the
right hand side I actually have the
opposite effect right so here's a
randomized control trial that would give
me a different outcome but I know I see
a couple of my students here and they
they can probably tell me because of the
central limit theorem if I were able to
do lots and lots of random uh randomized
control trials right I'm going to get
this distribution where I'm going to be
estimating the true treatment
effect okay
so you know Ruben I think in the 70s was
kind of starting to to publish under
this this new notion of kind of
estimating causality sort of he framed
it as a missing data problem right so
here's that figure and I only observe
one of these outcomes so but I want to
compare it to the other condition and
that value is missing and so propensity
score becomes one way to um potentially
get to that all right so I'm going to
skip over some of the details and just
kind of look at a simulated example in
general there's three major approaches
to to doing propensity score analysis
there's what's called
stratification matching or waiting so
we're going to look at all of them here
I'm creating a simple simulated data set
with um an assumed treatment effect of
1.5 and two co-variants that kind of
predict whether or not somebody's going
to be in the treatment or not so this is
kind of an observational data here's a
scatter plot so right away if you look
at this long enough hopefully you could
start to see that there's some kind of
kind of bias right thing about doing
propensity score analysis is kind of a
figure I created to try to outline the
steps um often for a long time I I I've
seen things talk about it in terms of
two phases um but I think the literature
lately is really it's really three
phases um so we take some our
observation observational data and we're
going to select the covariates we're
going to want to use often times uh it's
going to be what's available right if
you're using a secondary data set you
know you're going to use what's what's
going to be available however I've been
in situations where I've designed
studies where I think later on we might
want to estimate some causality or do
some kind of propensity score analysis
or even if we're doing a randomized
control trial if you're following like
say the what works Clearing House
standards there's a whole bunch of
things you need to collect to
demonstrate Baseline equivalents which
could potentially be used later um in a
PSA analysis then you're going to choose
some PSA method stratification matching
uh um what have you and then within
those there's kind of choices to be made
there's as we'll see out a slide there's
at least a dozen different matching
algorithms that you could use and then
you're going to check balance and by
check balance what I mean is I'm going
to look at an observation that's in the
treatment control and these are the
units that I want to make compar
do they look roughly equivalent on The
observed variables that I have or
co-variants and I'm going to repeat this
process until uh a sufficient balance is
achieved so I may need to add or remove
some covariants um maybe use a different
method re check the balance once I feel
like balance is sufficiently achieved
like so that when I'm going to make a
comparison in the outcome of interest um
it's between two things that are very
very similar I can then go to the phase
phase two where I actually estimate the
treatment
effects then lastly I'm going to run a
sensitivity analysis and the sensitivity
analysis very broadly is testing my my
um treatment effects to how sensitive
they are to an unobserved confounder in
other words I have here are the 12
co-variants that I have that I'm trying
to model you know whether or not this
person chose the treatment or not how
much variance would another variable
need to have before I change my answer
right so that's kind of the notion going
on there and then lastly based upon a
paper um by Rosen bomb in 2012 we can
actually go back and use another method
to estimate the treatment effects and
what this does is can test the
sensitivity to our model choice so we
might have used matching then we can go
back and use stratification and what he
showed is that even when you adjust for
the type two error rate um that you may
actually achieve a little bit more power
and and and be able to check the
sensitiv so we're going to walk through
the steps of how to do all of
this so we think about stratification so
here from this simulated data I
estimated the propensity scores um in
this case just using logistic regression
but you can use any kind of modeling
technique I think last month somebody uh
gave a talk on BART methods that's a
great approach oh yeah right here thank
you uh that would be a great way to
estimate propensity scores um I use
random Forest a lot or classification
trees I'm not going to really talk about
those different model choic but I'll
point you to some resources where you
can where you can use this this is just
a simple logistic aggression um where I
just use this from my simulated data so
I have two co-variates and I'm
predicting treatment here so I'm not
even looking at my outcome yet so the uh
x-axis here is the propensity score it's
simply the fitted values from the
logistic regression that we're going to
interpret as a propensity score we can
interpret this as the probability of
being in the treatment and here I have
two density distributions so we could
see the treatment right the density for
the treatment is skewed over to the
right as we would expect right if
somebody is more likely to be in the
treatment we should see more on the
right hand side and then we kind of see
the opposite for the control units the
goal here with uh propensity score
analysis is that if we think about this
splitting things vertically here right
and what rosom Rubin showed in that 1983
paper is the propensity score
essentially becomes a univariate
reduction of the sort of multivariant
space of all the co-variates so now we
have a scalar value that we can so if
two people have similar propensity
scores they're going to be very similar
in all the variables that went into
estimating that propensity score so
stratification is one approach if you're
using classification trees the straa
simply become the leaf nodes of your
classification tree and for logistic
regression here I'm just using um
quintiles right I just divided it into
five equal groups such that this is
stratum a b CDE e and then when I
actually do the comparison in the
outcome I'm comparing the control units
to the treatment units in stratum a then
stratum B etc
etc this is a nice approach because you
end up using all your variables in my
world in the education World um there
tends to be imbalance between treatment
and control units so like for example my
dissertation work use the national
assessment of educational progress or
nape and I was looking at Charter
Schools versus traditional Public
Schools so I had you know nationally in
the United States about 3% of students
go to a charter school so about 3% of my
sample were treat what I would call
treatment and 97 were um uh control
units right and so sometimes when we see
matching units we end up leaving out a
lot of control units um but
stratification they're all going to kind
of be in there however because then you
end up with larger sample sizes you also
have sort of uh decreased or in um
deflated I would say confidence
intervals so sometimes you get
statistical significant results where it
may not be
practical right and so now this plot is
just so here the x-axis propensity score
um also propensity score but now I Chang
the y- axis to My outcome variable right
and so we can see here I'm doing
comparisons this is the control for for
stratum A B C D um now this is a
simulated data set such that the
treatment effect is kind of homogeneous
right it's about the same for each
stata um one thing I found really
interesting about propensity Square
analysis is it's a kind of an
interesting way of detecting um
heter um heterogeneous treatment effects
so a lot of times we see depending on
subgroups that the treatment may be more
effective or less effective as you go
through so it's often these things
reveal these things if we were to do
matching right so now what I have is on
the x-axis again the propensity score on
the y- axis is the outcome and I just
used a a basic matching algorithm and
the vertical lines are um uh the Matched
pairs that I found I also H Drew in a
Lois regression line of the difference
so we can kind of see that the treatment
effect is kind of constant throughout
the range of propensity scores um so
that's kind of what matching and this is
just using a um a a simple nearest
neighbor matching algorithm something
simple
um all right so couple things to note
right so on stratification when I'm
doing the comparisons here um I'm doing
independent sample tests when I go to a
matched I'm going to use dependent
sample T Test CU I'm matching individual
a with individual B and I'm going to do
the comparison there um this is just a
slide to show some of the many matching
algorithms sort of my general
recommendation is which one to use is
whichever one gives you the best balance
you're going to cycle through that
looking for balance before you actually
do the comparison on your
outcomes and then lastly propensity
score waiting is we can use the
propensity scores as a weight in some
other regression model and this is kind
of my way of trying to pick what's going
on here so um so the size of the circles
here so again propensity Square against
outcome um here I'm using a lowest
regression again um but I'm applying the
weight to the lowest regression and the
size of the points here for each
observation is how they're weighted so
you could see control units right if we
go back to the density distribution we
have fewer control units over on the you
know high end of the propensity score so
these units are going to be weighted
upweighted right these control units
that had high likelihood of being in the
treatment but happen to be in the
control so when they're compared to
their treatment counterparts in the same
range you know they're going to be
upweighted where on the on the lower end
we kind of see the reverse right we see
uh treatment units kind of have a higher
weight in that regression model on the
low
end so if you're so interested in that
PSA package um I wrote a little shiny
app to allow you to play with play
around with this I'm not going to go
into the different ways of um estimating
treatment effects I'm just going to use
the average treatment effect which is
very much the same as what we do in a
randomized control trial but it I would
be a Miss if I didn't point out that
often times there are other treatment
effects that you might be interested in
like average treatment under the treat
is often reported in in a propensity
score analysis but you can change um a
couple of options here like your sample
size and treatment effect and you can
kind of go through and see as I um
reduce the treatment effect what that
might look like so we could see here now
we have sort of overlapping confidence
intervals on these upper ranges um and
matching we can kind of see this is just
using the default GG plot um on the GM
smooth so this is an approximate 95%
confidence interval um and then uh
waiting so you can kind of play around
with this and see how things kind of
play out if you're so
interested all right so let's look at um
so here's the the actual rcode let's
look at some rcode um
nothing terribly fancy here I'm just
using the glm using a simple logistic
regression and getting the propensity
scores and then for stratification I've
wrote some utility functions if you want
uh which is really just a wrap to um the
cut and uh quantile functions in in R um
by default it gives you five breakes
that's I think roughly where there's a
reference by Cochran that said five is
generally sufficient depending on your
sample size sometimes they go up to 10
um straight up uh oh so you can see I
cut it here and the results of logistic
regression and so this is sort of again
another view of the distribution of
propensity score I'm going to skip over
these next oh okay never mind I got some
treatment effect
slides now this is my uh this is based
upon work of my adviser uh Bob pric I've
recently inherited uh the M maintenance
of the PSA Graphics package where this
comes from um but he introduced a whole
bunch of uh visualizations for uh
testing the um sort of quality or the
and the outcomes of propensity score
analysis so this is a what we what he
called a covariant multi I'm sorry a
multiple covariant balance plot and so
what we have here is we have three uh
predictors or three co-variates
predicting whether or not somebody is in
the treatment or not and what we're
looking at here is the red line is the
unadjusted effect size before we do the
propensity score adjustment right so in
other words this is how this variable is
affect ing um uh um the uh uh whether or
not they're in the treatment so you know
these are these are High um and so when
we do the propensity score adjustment
this is the average of um after
adjustment right so we're seeing what
the effect of that variable is after we
do the propensity score adjustment right
we want this to be as close to zero
we're trying to we're trying to
partition out that variance to the
treatment so that we can adjust for the
selection bias so this is a great way to
really quickly see how overall those
variables go down but we can look at
individual co-variance and how balance
is achieved so using a stratification
right so we have our five straa right
and so we can see on this particular
variable um you know for I don't know
what yeah so this is the X1 variable um
individuals with low scores in X1 are
more likely to be in stratum a right
with those in high values are more
likely to be in in Strat
five right and this uh these kinds of
plots I find tremendously useful
particularly at the end where I find
certain stata are more likely to
demonstrate treatment effects than than
other stata right and so it's like okay
what's going on so the first example I
came across this is um I was doing a
study with Head Start students um in
Upstate New York and um some students
were uh were able to get into head start
at as three-year-olds and others entered
as four-year-olds so what we were trying
to compare is whether or not there was
an increase in academic or social
outcomes for students who had two years
of Head Start versus one year of head
starts in the edsy world right this is
um this this is an important question
because uh a lot of theorists
particularly pans would argue that the
the exterior wouldn't matter because
three-year-olds aren't developmentally
ready right so them going to head start
is not going to really increase their
academic ability right so this is a very
very important question however um there
is a strong selection bias right the um
most needy families um tended to get
into head start earlier right but it
turns out not all of them got in early
because of other random choices and we
had a lot of very interesting variables
you know all the variables that that are
used to determine whether or not a child
is eligible for Head Start so we did
this analysis right and and the good
news was or depending on if you're a PJ
and the bad news is that like that extra
year actually did help but it didn't
help for one stra in particular and when
we went back and looked at the
co-variants it turned out the the ones
that were on the higher end of the
social economic status right they're
still technically in the poverty level
because you had to be in the poverty
level to qualify for but their families
were working but working at the poverty
level and were much more engag in the
family we went back and actually
interviewed some of them we found okay
they weren't they didn't actually
benefit as much of the extra year of
Head Start and we theorized because they
were getting supports at home um that
were sort of overlapping what was
happening in Head Start so this is a
case where I think determining heter
this is a great way of figuring out
whether or not there's a heterogeneous
Factor if the effect is different for
certain kinds of groups and the way we
discovered it is through these plots
right we were looking at well what is it
different about this particular group
and that was that stood
out all right so um I'm just going to
skip skip over these treatment effects
um because there's a lot of formulas and
I don't really want to talk about so I'm
going to walk through the sort of
classic example the the lawn data set um
which is a study from the 70s that
looked at the national support at work
demonstration um so Lon first used this
um data I think in the 80 oh yeah I have
it right there 1986 um what's nice about
this is it was a randomized control
trial but then there's this
observational data that kind of fell out
so we have a way of comparing
uh the propensity score analysis to a
randomized control trial um uh it was
found that the the so essentially these
were I think all males who were offered
um this training program and so we were
you know we're looking at how their
salary increased a few years later after
doing this training program we have a
whole bunch of variables in the
randomized control trial I think the the
effect was found to be somewhere between
76 ,000 pretty big range um uh so so
later maybe you know I don't actually
know how to pronounce these guys name
diaja and Waba do you know i' I've heard
a few different ways I've heard D MAV DJ
MAV okay my apologies if they're if they
happen to see this I've been butchering
your names for a very long time um so
they used this data set in
99 you know as a way of kind of seeing
how score analysis kind of it kind of
worked U the co-variates that are
available are age education level high
school degree marital status race
ethnicity earnings in
1974 and 1975 and our outcome of
interest is their earnings in 1978 so
it's available in virtually every
package that has to do with propensity
squore analysis I'm going to use the one
from the matching package um all right
and so as we walk through the steps here
so the first step so here's my formula
um actually not using um the one they
used because they had some quadratic
terms I think when they found the best
model fit um but for simplis sake I'm
I'm leaving it out and just doing the
simple linear
regression uh you know probably
everybody's familiar with logistic
regression in R I'm getting the
propensity scores as the fitted values
I'm defining um my my stratifications we
could see the summary um and we have
like Hispanic and um no degree which
always I always have to pause because
it's coded the reverse of how I would
interpret it um are are sort of the only
significant
predictors um if you if you have Insight
uh I've looked a lot in terms of the
literature in terms of deciding which
variables to
include um I saw one reference where uh
they had a threshold of saying if the P
value was was greater than 0.5 you could
probably leave it out um but but using
statistical significance testing as as a
a criteria for whether or not to include
a co-variate or not is not really the
best idea um particularly if you're
trying to explain results so I do a lot
of educational research and to not
include social Eon economic status as a
as a coari predicting whether or not
somebody chooses to be in the treatment
um even if it's not a statistically
significant effect would probably be
problematic to get it published right of
course you need to adjust for social
economic status regardless of what the
data
say so my next step is I'm going to
check balance so here I'm using this
covariant balance plot so we could see
as I would expect that the the um the
variables or the co-variants with the
larger uh significant effects are going
to be the ones that have the most
imbalance right so the red is before
adjustment so I'm going to do the
propensity score adjustment and get the
effect size for say no degree down to
less than 0.1 so it's it's accounting
for very little variance as we go
through
um I'm not going to go through every
variable but I would if I'm doing this
as a real analysis so here on the left
um here are some balance plots for for
continuous
covariants um so we could see stratum a
this is age right so stratum a is going
to be slightly younger people it sort of
somewhat increases linearly so I'm
looking for kind of balance here um we
could see on the right side I have real
earnings in 74 so those with the lowest
are near Z Z are probably likely to be
in stratum b or c um those with a
slightly higher uh 1974 might end up in
stratum e right but you take all these
in combinations you can kind of build
these
profiles um there's a few more and then
here's how I would look at categorical
variables um so on the right we have
Hispanic um so we see um so the one is
true so the white here I know it's like
kind of coded a little a little weird
here so if you're Hispanic you're almost
you're incredibly likely to be in in
Strat a now it turns out the a through b
here has to do with lower to higher
propensity scores so this also gives me
some indication that Hispanic um
individuals were less likely to be um in
the training program or receive the
treatment um so they're going to end up
in the lower stratum so we could go
through here's another one that's pretty
pretty um prevalent so those who um did
have a degree right were more likely to
enroll into the um into the uh
Intervention which might intuitively
make some sense so when we make
comparisons um those who do have a
degree are going to be likely compared
to one
another uh this is typically the the
plot I start with um which kind of puts
everything I did leave the points off
because there was a large number of
observations and it just kind of
cluttered the plot but what I have here
up at the top is my distribution of
propensity scores right so the things
I'm looking for is that is is there
sufficient overlap and whether or not
there's sufficient um sort of division
between the treatment and control um I
always find this data set even though
it's like the seminal work that
everybody uses um to be a little bit
problematic in terms of really
separating um the treatment and control
units in a meaningful way so I get this
you know hump here and but there's nice
overlap over all um the uh this panel
here is if you can turn your head to the
right uh is essentially the distribution
of the differences um before adjustment
all right um so this is just the
distribution of the
outcomes um there's also a scaling
problem I probably should lock transform
maybe the um the the outcome variable uh
and then here are just the two lowest
regression lines so the green line is
the treatment group and the and the red
line so we could see for individuals
like in this particular range of the
propensity score the treatment seems to
be a little bit larger and we have
almost no treatment effect here you know
sort of on the lower
end if we were to do this a
stratification right what are we doing
it within each stata we're doing um
dependent sample T tests and that's what
these horizontal lines are so again
looking at the stratification we really
only see the the treatment effect is
really being heavily um you know
influenced by just those on the higher
end of the propensity score range um and
so on the left I I use five straa on the
right I use 10 10 stata um so that's the
only difference
here this is a a PSA assessment plot um
here what we have is for each straa
we're plotting the control units on the
x-axis and the treatment units on the Y
AIS um the coordinates are equal we have
the unit line line right so this is the
line yals X so any points that fall on
the line yal X means the difference is
zero and what we're doing here is
projecting each of these down to a line
perpendicular to the unit line right so
these little x marks essentially
represent the distribution of
differences within each STA and this
green line repres I'm sorry the dashed
Blue Line would then be the mean
difference and then the green line is
the 95% confidence interval and you know
once you get used to reading this what
you're looking for is does this green
line span the line yal X if it doesn't
then you have a statistically
significant effect if it spans a line
then the confidence interval will span
zero right we would not reject the null
hypothesis and here on the left is five
versus 10
straa that's the uh output if you want
to see it so in terms of matching um I'm
just using the match package there's two
majors there's the match and the matchet
um
when you pass this in um I always end
with matching although intuitively makes
the most sense right often what we want
to do or when I explain it to lay people
who aren't statisticians what I want to
do is say I if I have a treatment unit
or a treatment student I want to find a
control student that looks just like
them in almost every way or at least
every way that I can measure right
that's our goal and then we're just
going to do a dependent uh null
hypothesis test to do that comparison
and as I mentioned before there are a
lot of matching algorithms this one is
just using the nearest neighbor couple
of parameters to point out here is this
m right so we could do um one to one
matching so for each treatment we match
to exactly one control if you have
imbalanced data you could do each
treatment to two three four five
whatever um control folks can do that um
um so it depends on your your context
when I talk to folks like in the
biomedical world um they have pretty
strict that each observation can only be
used once right so in this try match
package everybody's like okay I get
candidates but I need each one um only
used once um because that seems to be
what their journals want um and so when
you go through here right we get an
estimate um so this is a treatment
effect this is in dollar so um using
this one we would estimate the treatment
effect is about $2,500
more and then this is uh sort of an a um
analog to what I showed before except
now what we have and if you're doing any
dependent test I I love this plot a lot
um because what we're doing is plotting
the treatment on the x axis and the
control on the y- AIS so each point
represents a match pair so an individual
who was um in the treatment and one who
was not and those are the ones we making
the comparison so everything in terms of
principles is the same we project these
down to a line perpendicular so these
points right here represent the
distribution of different
scores right the um of course different
person wrote it uh it's a green line
that represents the bean difference and
the blue um and what you can't see here
because there's a lot of observations
there's this little purple line right
here that's the confidence interval so
it's pretty small here and it doesn't
span
zero so for matching um this is sort of
a plot I developed to try to uh
help me evaluate um matching I know it's
kind of complicated um I don't publish
this but I use it to check for things
what I have here is um each sort of
little vertical line if you imagine on
the x- axis is a
matched pair right so I've taken a
treatment person and matched them to a
control person and what I do is I color
right so then this here is the no degree
variable then I have education uh black
real earning 74 real earning 75 Hispanic
age and married if there's a color that
means those two did not the the there's
a difference in their observed in The
observed coari for that variable so and
I try to order it so we can see over on
the left right so there's 2% of my
matched pairs um I think that's I can't
tell what that is it got chopped off but
it's like nearly 80 % right so they
didn't match on 80 so for 2% of my
matched pairs they only really matched
exactly on 20% of the covariant so
that's kind of problematic right um I
have to go down to you know once I get
to
20% um so in other words 80% exactly
matched down at least half the covariant
okay um so I could see that this way
right and that's what these are and then
I could see overall for like no degree
which is an important variable um you
know 9% didn't match exactly but 81% did
so some of these are really um sort of
kind of problematic a no degree up here
in this upper panel gives me the
confidence interval of the effect um
after adjustment so no degree is still
not really I don't have sufficient
balance um so if you're playing around
with this how I use this often so if I
go to let's use the lon data set so
here's a shiny app I'll I'll show it in
a moment right I can go into the
matching I'm sorry
balance so often what you can do here um
is in for those variables that are sort
of kind of problematic you can do
partial exact matching right so if no
degree is a really important variable
for predicting whether or not somebody
chooses to be in the treatment I may
want to ensure that when I make a
comparison they match exactly on that
variable so in the shiny app I can play
around with this and say okay let me
check this box right and now I have
perfect balance on the no degree
variable but I can see how that impacts
the rest of my matching Al algorithm um
as I go through so this is often how I
play around with to decide which
variables the problem is if you specify
too many as exact matching the
candidates that to get matching becomes
a little bit more
challenging right and then if you're
doing it in code um I kind of
highlighted here how you would do that
all right great so we have a treatment
effect now what do we want to do we want
to test the sensitivity of our of our
model to unobserved co-variants
um so right so our our estimate is only
as good as how well we adjust it for the
selection bias and so what sensitivity
analysis is going to do is kind of make
this presumption that if I add another
variable and it accounts for a certain
amount of variance um you know how does
it change and it's doing this um sort of
looking at the odds odds ratio as we go
across and we're kind of systematically
increasing um I'm not going to go
through all the details for the for the
sake of time um but um this is what the
output looks like so I'm using uh a
package called R bounds to do this and
it really only works with with matched
propensity score matching um if anybody
knows of a way to do this with
stratification or waiting that would be
nice to know um and it kind of got
truncated but here we could say so we
have this gamma and so essentially if
we're adding 10% more variance in
explaining our outcome this is how the
bounds of our P value would change and
so what we're looking for is if we have
like 40% more that's where our upper
bound um is greater than 05 so we would
no longer reject the null hypothesis so
that gives us a sense of how sensitive
so and this this uh with the Lan data
set and the national uh demonstration
work program is is very sensitive
actually I think to uh unobserved
confounders um I've looked at
sensitivity analysis like smoking right
which is another case where we never
randomize somebody to smoking or not um
for for those studies the sensitivity is
something like six like 6.0 it's like
very very large very unsensitive if you
will to unobserved Compounders like
we're we're pretty sure smoking causes
cancer I think at this stage even though
we did not randomize people um to
smoking or
nonsmoking all right so one of when I
read Rosen bomb's paper in 2012 and he
talked about you know testing a null
hypothesis more than once um which say
you know one of the things you can do is
test the sensitivity to model Choice
which got me thinking like well what
could I do bootstrapping here right and
so this is another approach I like to
use a lot to kind of at least give me
some sense of where where the models are
and it sort of you know helps me try
lots of different things um so I wrote
this package called PSA boot um which is
sort of a take on bootstrapping it also
is very helpful um in situations where
you have imbalanced data because what
I'm going to do is um I'm going to take
bootstrap samples in the way you would
do a bootstrapping um but I'm going to
bootstrap separately from the treatment
and control so so that in each bootstrap
sample I have exactly the same number of
treatment and control right so if I have
100 treatment and 900 control I'm going
to in each bootstrap sample I'm going to
have 100 treatment and 900 control
there's some parameters where you can
tweak that so if you have imbalanced
data I could say well I can actually
just use my treatment every time don't
do any random sampling or you know set
replacement defaults and I'm only going
to randomly select 100 control units and
I'm going to do that over and over right
so that's essentially down sampling my
control but then doing it lots of times
so that's one way you can do it or you
can do it in the typical
bootstrap but for each bootstrap sample
I'm going to estimate the propensity
score I'm going to sorry I'm going to
estimate the treatment effects using
multiple methods stratification matching
and weighting and there's a whole bunch
of parameters so you can try it a whole
bunch of different ways um this is what
the r code like so I I specify my
treatment variable My outcome and my co
you know a matrix of covariant and then
my formula for estimating the propensity
sore and so here's one output plot so
the um the red line here represents the
unadjusted uh difference right if I
didn't do any adjustment propensity
Square
adjustment um the Blue Line represents
the oh I'm sorry this is a balance I'm
sorry yep so this is looking at the uh
average
balance across all the co-variants so
the Blue Line shows what the balance is
just using the full data set no
bootstrapping right just plain
propensity score analysis and then the
black line is sort of the average of
this distribution here so this black
line is the distribution of balance um
for all the bootstrap samples and the
vertical black line is the average so we
can see in this example right so on the
top is the SE tree this is in the party
package I'm using matching package the
match it package R part uh simple
stratification and uh waiting so in this
example we can see waiting actually has
the best balance of all the
methods so we can take that the next
step and look at our outcome so here um
what we have is I think I did about I
think I did 100 bootstrap samples here
so there's 100 lines so these are the
confidence intervals for all 100
bootstrap samples and if if it's red it
means it the confidence rval doesn't
span zero um this dark blue line and the
green lines are the pooled mean and uh
confidence interval across all of
them um we can look at it as a box plot
which I think is a little bit easier so
we can see here's the distribution of
effect sizes across all the bootstrap
samples um with the pooled and unpooled
um ones in
there here where I find it most
interesting um is where this Pais plot
shows me for each bootstrap sample you
know what are the correlations or what's
the relationship between the effect
sizes between these different methods um
and having done this for a while I know
our part um is sort of a common uh
classification method because it's built
into um b r uh you know and I think
people know this already right it has a
tendency to overfit so unless you prune
it it's not going to perform very well
and I I I think kind of shows up here we
can see it kind of um doesn't perform
very well compared to other things or is
a little bit more noisy shall we
say how are we doing on time Jared got
10 more minutes yeah all right so next
thing I've worked on is you know
situations where now I have two
treatments and one control so I want to
match on three and so this is a package
I wrote called try match um and here I'm
going to look at uh a data set where um
that I used to because I encountered
this problem when I was at uh an
Institutional research we had the
situation where a Dean came to me and
said hey we've been using um these
tutoring Services we want to know if
it's effective because we need to know
whether or not to renew the contract
right s of an external company that was
doing our tutoring of course we did no
randomization very much selection bias
but we had a pretty rich set of
variables available on our students but
we had this other issue where of the
student students who used the tutoring
Services we had you know about half of
them I think used it only once right and
then the other half used it two or many
times right so we kind of saw this clear
difference so we wanted to know well
what's the impact of somebody who uses
just tutoring once versus a a
reoccurring user a frequent user um this
is also related to some other research I
I I look at in terms of self- regul
learning and help-seeking right these
are kind of constructs that are really
important um right and so that that's
and I was kind of thinking about this I
great um there was one only at that time
when I wrote this there was one other um
paper that was looking at this but it
had to do with A continuous treatment
not a categorical so um uh so you can
read this later I'm going to try to
explain it from the picture since I I
titled this a visual
introduction so in essence what I do
here is I'm going to be estimating three
logistic regressions right so model one
is I'm going to just take the treatment
one in this case this would be students
using tutoring Services once and
treatment two is students who used it
two or more times so I take students in
the control and treatment one and
estimate a logistic regression um and
get their propensity scores then I'm
going to take control and treatment two
and estimate a logistic regression right
and then treatment one and treatment two
right so I end up with these three sides
of a
triangle now what I do is I start um and
you can tweak this in the algorithm but
I usually start with the smallest and
then the second smallest Group by
default right so I want to because I
want to optimize for the the group that
has the fewer observations thinking that
if I'm going to leave observations out I
want it to be from the larger group and
typically that's going to be the control
group um so the algorithm goes through
and it considers um so it's really just
doing a nearest neighbor algorithm right
but what it does is once I find a
candidate of nearest neighbors usually
within some caliper or some threshold
right I'm going to consider all of the
matches right so here I have um right so
I'm going to find uh a treatment one
student that looks like this control
unit well that student also is
represented in this model right so each
individual is on two edges right and so
the red and the green lines are
essentially just connecting right so if
we look at this individual um this is
their propensity score in this model is
are a treatment unit okay but they don't
represent here so what I'm going to do
is find for this control I find a
treatment one they're close I have a
whole bunch of them close I'm going to
pair them over there and find um you
know individuals that are in treatment
two that are close to that one and then
kind of finish the circle adding the sum
of the distances between those three
models standardized um and a step of the
way if they're too far away or that's
some gets too large I throw them away so
there's a bit of a greedy algorithm kind
of going through as I kind of translate
so the goal here is to find individuals
right sort of connecting in that missing
that missing connection so what ends up
happening at the end of the algorithm is
you end up with a match
triplet um so of course I have balance
plots to look at this so I can see um
you know the the red line is the
unadjusted so this is 1 2 and three
corresponding to one uh oop so one two
and three here right so we could see uh
on average the the balance is generally
pretty well achieved in the match
triplets um and then we can look at the
outcomes here there's some other
diagnostic that I'm kind of glossing
over here um you can do like repeated
measures of Nova for continuous
variables and uh Freedman rank sum tests
for categorical variables if you want to
get a little bit more fine grade and
ensuring that you have sufficient
balance um and so now what we can do
here is um and I think there's a bonon
adjustment on here if I remember
correctly uh um we can now compare so
here we have treatment one versus
control so we can see a student who
uses treat the tutoring Services once um
got3 higher uh you know uh so
essentially if they if they were going
to get an 80 they now got an
83 right um
so and for you know those who used it
two or more times uh had a basically a
double the treatment effect and then and
then this is the difference between
treatment one and treatment two
unfortunately I need to fix this I did
treatment one minus treatment two so the
negative is just because of the way I
did the the um
subtraction last thing and this is the
oldest thing because this was my
dissertation work was to uh PSA with
multi-level data um in a lot of ways
matching or at least partial exact
matching is one way you could do
multi-level um right so if if say if I'm
looking at students within a school
within a district right I could in in
the matching algorithm say well I need
to match exactly on like the school
right and that's kind of looking at that
clustering in a meaningful way so when I
get matched pairs I can do that you
could potentially part partition that
out and do some post Hawk analysis but
what I wanted to do is I wanted to use
um um stratification methods right um as
I mentioned one matching is
um but one limitation is particularly
when you have imbalanced data um you
know matching you're you're often
leaving out some observations where
stratification kind of tends to use all
of them and so and you know again as I
mentioned I think uh I used the national
assessment of educational progress
looking at Charter Schools versus
traditional Public Schools um rest it's
a restricted use license I can certainly
send you that that study if you want but
just the demonstr what's going on here
I'm actually using the Pisa data the
program for international student
assessment from oecd so here I'm looking
at private versus Public School sort of
just kind of
parallel um which is looking at the
outcome of
um uh 15-year-olds in reading and
Mathematics and uh science I think I'm
looking at here math yeah I'm just
looking at math
outcomes um and there's a couple ways
you can do it so here I'm using um the
sea tree method or the classification
tree that's in the party package I find
it quite good in terms of its defa I
think it's default trees tend to perform
quite well they're not they don't it
doesn't overfit like our par does and
requires less pruning and um after the
fact um so here's a um tree plot for the
covariant but I just want to get to this
plot because this is what where I think
this can be interesting and useful is
because we're doing essentially
propensity score estimates and then um
pulling them to to aggregate Above So
this plot is very much like the ones I
showed before except here each circle um
corresponds with a country so um I think
this is the my Legend is missing um this
is United States um this is Canada no
I'm sorry this is Mexico and this is uh
Canada so I just use North America for
um computational efficiency here right
for a demonstration um so when I did my
study as part of my dissertation I had
all the states that had Charter School
laws right and so I could see the how
students in different states that had
different Charter School laws performed
differently right and that's kind of
what I was interested in is like some
southern states have sort of much looser
rules on how Charter Schools can operate
and it turns out probably not a big
surprise the effects for them are worse
than say states that have sort of more
regulation on how Charter Schools can
form
um and this is just another way of
looking at the difference as confidence
rals I'm sorry the green is not the best
color on a projector um so these are the
confidence intervals and the dashed
green lines are with a bonferoni
adjustment all right and I kind of
already showed this um but if you're not
so interested in coding everything up in
R um the shiny app is on GitHub and
there's some built-in data sets but you
can also upload your data set to it so
if we go to let's look look at my
tutoring uh data set um you pick your
treatment you can pick your outcome then
you can pick your co- variates that you
want to include that are in the data set
um you can pick the number of straight
you want to use between 5 and 10 and
this is the partial exact matching so
typically you want to go in and you know
first look at the distribution
propensity score so here's the results
of a logistic
regression um of course you want to go
look at balance which I already kind of
looked at a little bit um we can look at
the results if we do a matching analysis
we can look at the results for a Lois
regression um or stratification you can
see here if I make this 10 I get more
more straight to look at um and if you
all look at the raw data so that's uh
available and then that sort of
concludes my talk and happy to take as
many questions as you
want
please repeat the question so people
have don't
gotcha are you monitoring the online I
am okay that's always goog online are
always more shy than in person that's
interesting it's the quiet time I'm I'm
actually terrible at the weight time as
an instructor I need to be quiet for
what 15
seconds so first of all really really
cool talk I could definitely see using a
lot of these tools on my own analysis
which is more than I can say for a lot
of talks that I I see um I I had a
question in particular about the triplet
matching so matching like the one of the
Prime problems being that you throw away
units right so is it not kind of an
extra concern if you have multi- level
absolutely through potentially like
three times or exponentially more
units yeah
um very much so and this is I'm still
working on I haven't published the paper
on this um some people have found it and
used it I haven't really publicized it a
lot because I've worked um I've taken
the um by default it sort of does more
caliber matching in other words if the
match triplets are sort of within a
certain caliber right and I think by
default it's 0.25 that's what a lot of
use um I tend to make it a little bit
smaller for my own work um
so the resulting data frame you get back
that has sort of here is the match
triplets um reuses lots of
observations and so in if you go to the
vignette for the package I explain that
it's you really need to take the effort
to reduce it right and say so that's
where I know from the medical because
that's the emails I get I'm I'm studying
this effect of this drug right but I can
only have each observation once what
should I do right and so um I'm still
trying to write some there's some
utility functions in there that help you
do that but really you want to take that
um take that data frame and like sort it
by the um propensity score distances
right the difference between the
propensity scores so you could just do
like the non- duplicator or any of the D
plier functions and just prune so that
you know but it's s i kind of leave that
up to the researcher because um in some
cases you may you may want to just use
that use all the data you have and it
means using some observations more than
once the the problem with that um is
that your confidence intervals tend to
shrink because you may be inadvertently
inflating your nend right so um you may
need to do some adjustments there um but
yeah I would love to have more
conversations with other folks on not
actly sure how to handle that um because
you'd end up with a lot of
candidates I don't think I repeated the
question but the question was uh uh
don't you end up with uh throwing away
or not using data when you have the
match triplets it's kind of a worse
situation short answer is yes that's
it's a
problem we have time for a
handful so do charter schools actually
do anything or is it all all right so
the question is about Charter Schools
this is a very political question
uh
um so the charter school advocates would
tell you that not our all charter
schools are the same right they're all a
little different on average there's no
difference they perform the same as
traditional Public Schools um in the
nape I there enough Kip
schools right to Warrant sort of a
subanalysis so Kip schools do perform
better among uh charter schools and and
do perform marginally better than their
Traditional School counterparts but then
there are a lot of schools who perform
worse right so it has to balance out
because in average it's it's not null So
my answer to that right to the Charter
to charter school advocates is well
they're not all the same you can't lump
all Charter Schools together my answer
is like but in the law you're proposing
Charter Schools as a wholesale
replacement for traditional Public
Schools so you open yourself to that
comparison so um it's it's sort of like
if you're going to do this then you need
to police yourselves and and like if you
have bad charter schools so I think we
already have a system if we want to do
experimental schools we have magnet
schools right um and and if you read Ray
Bud's original work from the 90s what
charter schools are now and what he
Envision them to be is completely
different I think that you know they've
gone completely astray so there's my
political statement on it it's my
political opinion it's uh but the data
does not support Charter Schools as sort
of a wholesale replacement of
traditional Public
Schools yeah thanks for the talk is very
interesting um so can you use prity
scores even if you have like
low like let's say you have 50 control
50 treatment or
for high uh I I mean you're doing
probably as much work on this I would
right um working with Jennifer Hill I in
general bigger ends the better um
it's
because um it's really really
challenging and and and I think the uses
for this at least in my world right so
the department of Ed does all these
really large scale studies and they make
this data available or Pisa or oecd if
you're in the economics World um so
that's where it's really useful in these
large observational data sets where
there might be some kind of indication
of some kind of treatment or maybe it's
a natural experiment or something like
that I also see it used I get emails
from folks um where they do a randomized
control actually my own work I'm I'm I
have a grant right now where we're doing
a large scale randomized control trial
and we still do a propensity score
analysis to test for violations in the
randomization process right that's kind
of an a way to um to do that now luckily
we our our protocols have been pretty
good but I've seen studies where you
know particularly in the medical world
doctors have favorite patients who kind
of nudge them into the intervention
right and so for the researchers It's
Kind it's kind of a useful way to detect
those um those violations of the
randomization process protocol so bigger
n is my answer I don't know if there's a
a rule of thumb of how big
but big well I guess follow question is
if your an is small do you have a
preferred method of using propensity
scores amongst any of the ones that you
show
today
um so I I mean quite honestly I always
start with the lowest plot um because
you're using all your data
um like this one right this is sort of
my first diagnostic plot this gives me a
sense of everything because all my data
is here all observations are being used
now when I do matches right if it's just
simple propensity Square matching right
it's just going to be vertical lines uh
you know essentially you they're like
little slices here and if it's
stratification I'm I'm actually dividing
boundaries um
so this is kind of kind of where I start
and then I move out from from
there question yeah your sensitivity
analysis have you found any consistently
underperforming
models oh good so the question is is um
are they're consistently underperforming
with sensitivity
analysis
uh our part
um uh really uh which is I still I see
it in the predictive modeling world
people using it and I sort of as an on
you know if you're not unless you're
going to prune it and actually look at
it but if you're just going to use the
default I don't I would stay away from
it is my opinion
um I don't other than that not not
really I don't think I've seen any
Trends uh so oh last thing I want to
point out so if you go to psa. bri. org
my last name very early stages of doing
a book down chapter one I think gives a
written of almost everything I presented
you'll see a lot of common
visualizations here the rest of the
chapters are sort of if you want the r
code to do things um I'm working on kind
of filling it out um so so that's uh so
you can kind of see the The Waiting or
or um you know stratification but the
thing I want I I alluded to before um is
like I said I just use logistic
regression um go to our to the October
talk and and hear about bart methods um
which might be a better way of
estimating propensity scores in the
logistic regression um so in this
appendix this is right now just um uh
here oh here's the BART um if you want
to use BART to estimate propensity score
so these are different ways if so if we
go back to um oh where I lost my space
um so
uh this figure here right this choose
PSA method really I mean there's a
couple things if you're using matching
different matching algorithms um but if
you're but even within the match if
you're doing matching with propensity
scores um you may want to use this the
society for causal inference right I
think you made reference to this I think
Bart wins it this competition every year
or is second if not first so um but I
didn't want to talk about bart you go go
to October's
[Laughter]
recording all right then big round of
applause please thank thank
you
okay so thank you very much for the
great talk and this talk came about cuz
I was asking as anyone want to give a
talk he emailed me saying he wants to
give a talk so I expect two people in
this room today and two people virtually
to email me within the next two days
they want to give a talk soon all right
then we'll have some excellent talks for
those of you in the room we are going to
arts and crafts bar after we break down
all the equipment or whoever knows how
to get there lead the way and I'll break
down the equipment and meet you next
month we gonna have we're gonna have a
scheduled as soon as someone volunteers
to give a talk and those just have a
great time so thank you very much
everyone for attending and one more
round of applause for our
speaker and have a good night see you
next time